el gobernador de Florida en republicano
ron de santis ya ha firmado la polémica
ley anti inmigrante que pone en jaque a
los indocumentados del Estado la
normativa que entrará en vigor el 1 de
Julio entre otras cosas obliga a las
empresas a utilizar un sistema para
verificar el estatus migratorio de los
trabajadores invalida las tarjetas de
identificación que algunos estados dan a
los indocumentados también requiere que
los hospitales recopilen información
sobre el estatus migratorio de los
pacientes y castiga con penas de hasta
15 años de prisión a quienes transporten
a indocumentados la ley también
contempla un presupuesto de 12 millones
de dólares para llevar a migrantes
indocumentados a otros estados del país
un plan que el Gobernador ya había
llevado a cabo a pesar de las críticas
de los demócratas en un principio el
proyecto castigaba con penas de cárcel a
los ciudadanos estadounidenses por
convivir en la misma casa con alguien
sin papeles Pero finalmente gracias a la
presión de la bancada azul y
Pro inmigrantes ese punto se eliminó
Igualmente avisan que hay mucho temor en
el estado y algunos activistas aseguran
que muchos migrantes ya están pensando
en abandonar Florida al considerar que
se ha convertido en el estado más
antimigrante del país y recuerdan que
los campos de agricultura y otros
sectores como la construcción podrían
verse afectados ante la falta de mano de
obra que normalmente la cubren en
personas sin estatus legal el gobernador
republicano ron de santis se defiende y
dice que solo hace que ampararse bajo la
ley que se está preparando para un
tiempo que él califica como turbulento
ante la previsible llegada de miles de
migrantes indocumentados otros critican
que esto Solo es una maniobra
electoralista para presentar su
candidatura a las elecciones
presidenciales aunque él no lo